نتابع واياكم مشاهدينا الكرام هذه التغطيه
اذا ارحب بكم ونذكر باخر الاخبار العاجله
التي وردت حتى الان على الاقل في الساعه
الماضيه وكنا عرضنا صورا لمبان مدمره فيها
تايجر راى هذا الزلزال الجديد ولحظه وقوع
الزلزال في ريف حلب بسوريا كان نائب رئيس
تركيا فؤاد اقطعي قال انه لا داعي للقلق
من ارتفاع مستوى البحر بعد الزلزال ولم
اخاوف من امكانيه ارتفاع منسوب مياه البحر
البحر حتى الان تحدث عن ثماني اصابات جراء
الزلزال الاخير في هاتاي مع معلومات وردت
عن تسجيل 20 هزار ارتداديه منذ وقوع
الزلزال الجديد هناك كان هناك معلومات تم
تداولها عن الرئاسه التركيه عن مطالبه
المواطنين بالابتعاد عن البحر خشيه من
ارتفاع منسوب المياه قبل ان تاتي الطمانه
من نائب الرئيس اذا الاعلام التركي تحدث
عن بدء البحث والانقاذ عقب التقارير عن
وجود عالقين تحت الانقاض فيما وزير داخليه
تركيا يتحدث عن اربعه اشخاص تحت الانقاض
في انطاكيا وعن مقتل امراه في سمنداك بعد
سقوط حجر على راسها الى عضو في البرلمان
التركي يهرب اثناء لقاء تلفزيوني بعد حدوث
الزلزال الاخير اذا نشاهد
[موسيقى]
اذا كانت هذه صور لنائب تركي وهو يهرع
مباشره الى الخارج على اثر شعوره بحدوث
الزلزال وذلك اثناء
تلفزيوني واثناء بث مباشر
يعني الى الخارج تخوفا من هذا الزلزال
حاكم انطاليا التركيه كان اتحدث او طلب
المواطنين بالابتعاد عن سواحل البحر ايضا
وزير داخليه تركيا نذكر بانه قال وصلتنا
بلاغات عن سقوط مباني في سمندغ وانطاكيا
جراء الزلزال الاخير حاله من الرعب والهلع
في عدد من المناطق والدول في شرق المتوسط
لا نتحدث عن تركيا فقط عن سوريا مره جديده
عن لبنان عن دول اخرى شعرت ايضا بهذه بهذا
الزلزال رامي عبد الرحمن مدير مرصد السوري
معنا الان ليطلعنا على اي معلومات جديده
لديك استاذ رامي اهلا بك نعم مساء الخير
طبعا
نتيجه القفز من الشرفات المنازل السقوط
بعض الحجاره حقيقه الامر على رؤوس الذين
او على على
الفرار ولكن حتى اللحظه الحمد لله لا يوجد
اي وفيه في سوريا هناك 42 اصابه في مناطق
سوريا مختلفه ولكن الغالبيتها اما نتيجه
الهلع والتدافع او القفز من شربات المنازل
او سقوط بعض الحجاره لدى محاوله الفرار
ولكن حتى المباني التي سقط اجزاء منها او
حتى سقط يعني سقطت بشكل شبه كامل كانت
بالاساسيه
متصدعه ومنهاره في
احياء حلب سقطت اجزاء من مباني ايضا في
حجاره من مباني تساقطت في الاثاره على
سبيل لو تكرمت هذه صور منها لحاله الرعب
والهلع التي اجتاحت المنطقه والسكان طبعا
الذين هرعوا من منازلهم ومن شققهم الى
الطريق العام بعد الزلزال خلال فتره وقوعه
بعضهم نرى صور خلال فتره وقوع الزلزال
والبعض الاخر من من فرعوا الى الخارج بعد
هذا الزلزال او في خلاله تحسبا لما يمكن
ان
اضافه الى ما كنت تتفضل به ايضا استاذ
رامي تاكيد من رائد صالح على تويتر وهو
يراس الخوه البيضاء بان الاصابات التي
وصلت الى المستشفيات كانت نتيجه للقفز من
الطوابق العليا او حالات اختناق نتيجه
الخوف او حوادث سيارات نتيجه حاله الهلع
التي سببها الزلزال والفرق المتخصص ما
زالت بحاله تفقد للابنيه التي انهارت اذن
مراسلنا يتحدث عن اهزى ارتداديه جديده في
هاتاي التركيه بعدما وردت الكثير من
الانباء عن هزات ارتداديه حصلت في تلك
المنطقه في الساعه الاخيره ويعني هذا
طبيعي بعد حدوث زلزال بهذه القوه او
زلزلين متتاليين وبالتالي لنا ان نترقب
بعضا من الهزات الارضيه
الاخرى الان
احمد ابو لؤي معي
اذا الصحفي ماذا لديك يعني ما اخر
المعلومات حيث انت
استاذ احمد تسمعني
الصوت يتقطع ممكن تعيد لو سمحت
نعم اسمعك بوضوح تفضل نعم بالفعل يعني
نتيجه هذه الهزه القويه او
فيما نقول
يعني
عدد او مئات العائلات
القاطنين ضمن بعض المباني الى الشوارع الى
الساحات في هذا البرد القارس نساء شيوخ
اطفال اوضاع ماساويه توتر اصبح ملحوظ بشكل
كبير استنفار كبير لسيارات الاسعاف طبعا
هنالك بعض المباني
التي يعني سقطت بشكل جزئي في مناطق جنديرس
هنالك خمسه اصابات
نحن نتحدث عن خمس اصابات اذا هذا الاهم
بطبيعه الحال ولكن عدد المباني ايضا التي
انهارت
اعاده الصوت للتقطع الاستاذ رامي يعني ما
الذي تقوله هذه التطورات الاخيره الان
بالنسبه الى ما يمكن ان يحصل اعود اليك
بعد قليل استاذ احمد لعلنا يعني نصلح
الخلل في التواصل معك ارجو ان تبقى معنا
استاذ رامي عبد الرحمن ما الذي تقول هذه
التطورات الاخيره تفضل يعني حاله الهلع
والخوف وحاره الرعب التي يعيشها السوريين
عليها حتى دمشق التي كانت فيها تاثيرات
الهزه اقل
[تصفيق]
المواقع الان ما المعلومات عن هل في قتله
او اقتصر الموضوع على عدد اصابات قليل
وما حل فرقكم الان في في المدن والاحياء
منذ وقوع الزلزالين
منذ ساعه او تقريبا عملت على استنفار في
جميع مدن وقرى شمال غرب سوريا تفقدنا جميع
الاماكن وخصوصا الاماكن التي حدثت فيها
انهيارات سابقا خلال الزلزال الماضي يوجد
عدد من المباني التي سقطت وهي كانت مباني
مهدده وايه للسقوط سقطت في عده مناطق في
جنديرس وفي الظاهريه
والملاند وايضا يوجد بعض المنازل ايضا
التي هدمت بشكل كامل ولكن لله الحمد لا
يوجد اي شخص تحت الانقاذ هنالك بعض
الاصابات من من المدنيين هذه الاصابات
جراء التدافع الذي حصل بالاضافه ان هنالك
بعض
الاصابات كانت الناس تهرب الى الشوارع فمن
الاحجار التي تساقطت من تلك المباني يوجد
اصابات وايضا سجلنا بعض الاصابات
سقوط الاشخاص من الطوابق لذلك
الاصابات تراوحت ما بين الباب ومنطقه
الاتارب وايضا يوجد بعض الاصابات المتفرقه
طيب اذا الغاء التحذير الاحترازي بخصوص
ارتفاع منسوب مياه البحر وفقا لاداره
الكوارث التركيه الان وكان نائب الرئيس
تركي طمانه بهذا الشان بعد المعلومات التي
وردت عن تحذير وجهها بخصوص امكانيات
ارتفاع منسوب مياه البحر يعني التخوف من
تسونامي بعد اثر هذا الزلزال استاذ احمد
يعني ما طبيعه العمل الذي ستقومون به
الليله الناس يعني خائفون وهم في شوارع
وقد يبقون فيها على الاقل الليله يعني ما
المعلومات لابد وانكم تتواصلون مع خبراء
في هذا المجال بماذا يعلمونه يعلمونكم
استاذ احمد يزن جماعي
استاذ احمد يزجي عضو اداره الدفاع المدني
طيب
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه للفرق هي حاليا متواجده في جميع
المدن والقرى الى حد هذه اللحظه ونؤكد
الان انه لا يوجد اي شخص تحت الانقاذ
جراءها بعين الزلزالين
ولكن هنالك نحذر جميع اهلنا المدنيين
الذين حزرناهم سابقا من عدم العوده الى
المباني التي قيمت على انها مباني غير
صالحه للسكن لذلك نعيد ونحذر ايضا جميع
المدنيين من عدم العوده الى من عدم العوده
الى المنازل التي قيمت على ان منازل غير
صالحه للسكن خوفا من
الهزات الارتداديه يوجد بعض الهزات التي
رافقت هذين الزلزانين لذلك هنالك تخوف
كبير جدا الجميع الاهالي في جميع المناطق
في شمال غرب سوريا هم الان متواجدون في
الشوارع متواجدون في الساحات العامه بعضهم
يستقلوا سيارتهم بعضهم الان متواجد تحت
العراء حاله خوف كبيره جدا الكلمه الان
التي يتراود جميع المدنيين ذوينا الروح
ولا خيارات للاسف
لا خيارات كنا نطالب ان يكون هناك مخيمات
لاواء المتضررين جراء الزلزال الان يطالب
المدنيين جميعا ان يكون هنالك مخيمات لكي
تاويهم لكي يكون هنالك مكان امن يامون
اليه ولكن لا يوجد خيارات لدى المدنيين
سوى ان يستقلون سيارتها سيارتهم بالاضافه
ان يكونوا في الحدائق والساحات العامه
نشاهد على الخريطه
مكان وقوع الزلزال او يعني هذا امامنا
بوضوح الان
وهذه المنطقه هي
يعني
محافظ المنطقه التي وضعت التي يعني وقع
فيها الزلزال يقول ان الحاله صعبه جدا
الان يصف الحاله الصعبه اذا المنطقه هي
دفني فيها طائر التركيه عمدتها يتحدث عن
عالقين تحت الانقاض وعن ان فرق الانقاذ
تحاول التدخل اذن هذا هذه اخر المعلومات
يبدو يعني في تضرروا في عالقين تحت
الانقاض وفي بنايات سقطت نتحدث عن ازمه
جديده عن مشكله جديده قد لا تقارن بما حصل
ونامل ان يعني نقف عند هذا الحد كي لا
تقارن بما حصل سابقا في
زلزال السادس من فبراير نشاهد هذه الصور
من كاميرا مراقبه في غازي عنتاب للحظه
وقوع الزلزال
اذا نتابع واياكم مشاهدينا الكرام في رصد
ابرز واهم ما يصلنا من لحظات وقوع الزلزال
في
التركيه زلزال الذي كانت شدته ست درجات
فاصل اربعه على مقياس ريختر
قبل ان تنقل اداره الكوارث الزلزالا اخر
بقوه 5.8 درجات على وقع على مقياس الاخضر
طبعا وقع في سمندال
بالهاتاي الان عمده دفني فيها طائره تركيا
يتحدث عن عالقين تحت الانقاض وفرق الانقاذ
تحاول التدخل كان هناك دعوات من الرئاسه
التركيه كي لا يعود المواطنون كما هو
الحال في سوريا ايضا الى الابنيه
المتضرره جدا والتي قد تكون قايله للسقوط
يعني وهذا ما سجلتموه ايضا استاذ احمد في
في بعض مناطق سوريا
بسبب عدم وجود خيارات لدى الناس يضطرون
الى العوده منازل متضرره حتى لو كانت اي
للسقوط
[موسيقى]
وبعض الجدران ايضا كانت المتصدع ولكن
اليوم في هذين الزلزالين كان هنالك تصدع
ايضا جديد انهيارات جديده الان نراقب
الوضع فرق الدفاع المدني متواجده في
الاماكن العامه لحد هذه اللحظه الان لا
يوجد اي
مصاب تم نقله
الاصابات تم نقلها جميعا ولكن هنالك حاله
استنفار كبيرين هنالك ايضا بعض الفرق
المتواجده في المباني التي كانت سابقا
تشكل الخطر والان تشكل خطرا اكبر يوجد
الفرق هو عملت على اغلاق بعض الطرق لكي لا
يكون هنالك مرور للمدنيين من شركه نعود
اليك بعد قليل
الى هناك الوضع عندك الان محمود
نعم عزيزي الطاهر هي الصوره تختلف عن
الزالات التي الزلازل التي حصلت في
الفترات الماضيه بدايه القوه التي وصلها
هي تختلف ايضا عن الارتدادات ولكن هنالك
نقطه بغايه الاهميه هي ان التداعيات
السلبيه لهذا الزلزال وان كان السته على
عشره هي ايضا تداعيات ليست جسيمه بمقدار
الهزه ومقدار القياس لماذا لان اغلب المدن
التي ضربها الزلزال هي بطبيعه الحال خاليه
من السكان الابنيه المتصدعه هي لم تسكن
الابنيه المتهمه هي متهدمه حركه الناس
والسكان وان كان من مواطنين اتراك او من
نازحين هي محدوده جدا التواجد الاكبر
للمواطنين على مستوى هذه المحافظات ان كان
فيها تاي الى اورفا الى مدينه مالطا
ملاطيا الى هنا هي ايضا محدوده يعني
من النادر لان تجد مئه شخص مجمعين في
منطقه او قرب في بنايه الذي
طرا جديد هي ان الهزات تعود عليها
المواطنون بل ونحن ايضا تعودنا عليها ولكن
هذه المره خرجت عن المالوف وهي لم تكن
ايضا في اليابسه انما كانت في البحر وفي
المره الماضيه منذ ثلاثه ايام وتحديدا عند
الساعه الحاديه عشر ايضا كانت في البحر
لذلك ايضا عادت هذه المره في نفس المنطقه
وفي نفس البقعه لذلك اذا ذهبنا الى
الارقام التي تتحدث عنها الاعلام التركي
او تتحدث عنها الدوائر التركيه من نائب
لرئيس الجمهوريه او من وزراء هي محصوره
جدا لا تذكر نتحدث عن ثمانيه حالات جرحى
نقل الى المستشفيات نتحدث عن توقف لمطار
هاتاي نتحدث عن بعض المعلومات التي تقول
ان هنالك اشخاص تتحرك فرق الدفاع المدني
الجهوزيه المطلقه للمسعفين الدفاع المدني
العسكري جندرم الجيش القياده العسكريه حتى
الطيران يعني الان نحن في مدينه كانت
طائرات هي في حاله استنفار في الجو الاتقب
على الارض شرطه السير كل هذه الامور هي
تضع ان يكون التداعيات في نقاط محصوره
ولكن
يتحدث عنها الاعلام التركي بقوه اربع
درجات فاصل اثنين في سمنداغ ونائب رئيس
تركي نذكر بانه كان قال اضافه الى ما تفضل
به محمود قبل قليل بانه لا توجد اي
تهديدات او اخطار من الزلزلين الاخيرين
ولكن بطبيعه الحال سيكون هناك الكثير من
الهزات
الارتداديه ويعني هذه اضافه مني بعد ما
نقابل رئيس التركي تفضل
طاهر نحن نتحدث عن
4500 الى 5000 هزه ارتداديه في 16 يوما
اليوم استطيع القول سته عشر كنا نتحدث ما
قبل الامس عن اربعين هزه وقاربت الخمسه
المفارقه الاساسيه في هذه الهزه انها قفزت
من الخمسه الى سته وسته قليل من الاعشار
ولكن الذي كنت انا اريد ان اوضح الي ان
اذهب اليه ان اذهب اليه بالاشاره وليست
عمليه الاضرار الجسيمه بقدر ما هو عمليه
الهلع والخوف والارتياب والاضطراب النفسي
الذي رافق هنا في تركيا
وفقا للاعلام التركي بقوه اربع درجات فاصل
ثلاثه ونذهب ساقاطعك محمود نذهب الى
زيدان زنكلو معنا منها الطاي الان مراسل
العربيه زيدان تسمعني
ما الذي حصل عندك نعم الان دخلنا في مدخل
هاتاي عندما هناك حاجز للشرطه عند احد
انفاق طلبوا منا عدم استخدام الانفاق بشكل
كامل ابدا طبعا هي تدابير احترازيه لا
يوجد اي خطا كما ابلغنا لكن هي تدابير
احترازيه ايضا الطيران المروحي في سماء
هاتاي كما شاهدناه قبل قليل
لمراقبه الاوضاع والمتابعه فرق الانقاذ
استطيع ان اقول ان هناك حاله هلع كبيره
جدا لكن حتى الان الانباء التي تاتي منها
هناك انهيار لثلاثه مباني لم يكن بجوار
هذه المباني اي احد لكن هناك انهيار
لمباني اخرى كان هناك في جوار هذه المباني
اشخاص كانوا في جوار هذه المباني لذلك
السلطات تعتقد بوجود او تؤكد بوجود اشخاص
عالقين تحت الارقام طبعا في اضنه بحس
قبل قليل واتابع معكم العواجل
صباح حوالي لا يوجد اي انهيار لاي بناء في
اضنه لكن تم اخلاء المشفى كتدبير ضمن
التدابير الاحترازيه ايضا الحال في غازي
عنتاب اكد والي غازي عنتاب قبل قليل عدم
وجود اي انهيارات في الابنيه
المتصدعه بالنسبه الى موضوع طبعا مشفى
اسكندرون ايضا هنا في هاتاي يبعد حوالي
ساعه عن مدينه انطاكيا قال
عفوا اداره المشفى اخلت المشفى كضمن
التدابير الاحترازيه يعني نستطيع ان نؤكد
ان نحن اليوم مساء اليوم في الساعه
السابعه مساء قبل وقوع الزلزال بحوالي
ساعه غادرنا انطاكيا تقريبا استطيع ان
اؤثر تقريبا كل المباني
المتضرره او كل المباني المتضرره جراء
الزلزال الاول هي خاليه تماما وكان
وشاهدنا عمليات هدم لهذه المباني قد بدات
بعد الزلزال الاخير تبقى معنا زيدان من
هاتاي التركيه التي وصلها الان زيدان
نتابع ايضا واياكم مشاهدينا ونستمع لصوت
الطبيعي لانقاذ عريقين تحت الانقاض فيها
المعلومات الاوليه تشير الى انقاذ شخص
واحد من تحت الانقاب فيما تبقى ثلاثه
تحتها اذا على اثر هذا الزلزال في هاتاي
وعمليات
الانتشار والانقاذ لا تزال جاريه من الفرق
المتخصصه يعني لم تستطع هذه المناطق ان
تلملم جراحها واسلاها بعد زلزال السادس من
فبراير قبل ان تعود هذه المشاهد اليها من
جديد ولو ان الوضع الان لا يمكن ان يقارن
حتى الان بما حصل ان كان يعني كانت وسائل
اعلام تركيا افادت بتوقف حركه الطيران في
مطار هاتاي ومع انهيار مباني في المحافظه
اضافه الى محاولات الانقاذ الجاريه الان
هناك ولكن التحذيرات من خطر ارتفاع منسوب
البحر يعني كانت سحبت تم سحب التحذيرات
بهذا الشان ثم الرئيس التركي طمانه بهذا
الاطار ايضا هناك حاله هلع ورع بطبيعه
الحال في مختلف الدول المعنيه خاصه في
تركيا وسوريا ولبنان على اثر الزلزال
الاخير او الزلزلين الخيرين مع قله
الخيارات فيما يتعلق بدول معينه خاصه في
الشمال السوري اذا
زيدان زنكلو كما نقل لنا مراسلنا من هطاي
قبل قليل فان ثلاثه مباني انهار في تركيا
وان هناك مروحيات تراقب الاوضاع واسالك
هنا زيدان اذا كان موضوع المراقبه الامنيه
الجويه يعني كان سائدا ايضا في فتره
عمليات الانقاذ والانتشال الفتره الماضيه
ما بعد الزلزال سادس من فبراير يعني هذا
المعتمد العادي هناك
نعم عمليه المراقبه الجويه كانت في اليوم
الاول تحديدا منذ في اليوم الاول لوقوع
الزلزال الكبير في السادس فبراير طبعا
ايضا مراقبه استمرت ليست فقط في اليوم
الاول حتى اكون دقيق استمرت لعده ايام
خصوصا في الايام الحاكمه التي كانت تتفرق
الانقاذ تحاول الوصول الى اكبر عدد من
اليوم فورا يعني المنطقه كانت
مجهزه بشكل كامل
من قبل
يعني حتى الان يعني انقاذ لم تغادر
المدينه بشكل كامل ايضا
التركيه موجوده هنا لكل طواقيمها مع الف
وارق هذه الصوره لتضرر تبقى معنا اذن هذه
صور نشاهدها مباشره الانفصال جسر عن طريق
رئيسي فيها طاي بتركيا جراء الزلزال
الجديد
ونسمع بوضوح سيارات
الشرطه والاسعاف
تهرع في هذا الوقت الى هذه الامكنه التي
تضررت مع انتشار المروحيات للمراقبه
الجويه كما افادنا زيدان قبل خليل في
هاتاي كما درج عليه الحال في الايام
الاولى للزلزال الكبير في السادس من
فبراير اذن يعني هذه المعطيات الاوليه
الصور الاوليه الفيديوهات الاوليه التي
تريدنا لمختلف المناطق
المتضرره كان زيدان نقل لنا ايضا وجود
حواجز للشرطه تركيا التي تمنع استخدام
الانفاق كاجراءات احترازيه ليس لكل اجراء
ان يعني ان هناك ما وراءه او اسباب يعني
تحود دون ذلك مما يمكن ان يحصل في الساعات
المقبله ولكن كاجراءات احترازيه احيانا
هناك مباني بطبيعه الحال تتصدع تتضرر
وبالتالي ف السلطات تتخذ كل اجراءاتها
اللازمه لمنع سقوط قتلى وجرحى بسبب ما حصل
اذا هذه اخر الصور التي نشاهدها سياره
الاسعاف تمر من هذا الطريق اذا ونشاهد صور
انفصال الجسر اذا عن هذا الطريق الرئيسي
طبعا نحن سنتابع في تغطيتنا المستمره لرصد
ساعات ما بعد الزلزال وما يمكن ان يحصل
وفقا لخبراء الزلازل والمتخصصين في هذا
الموضوع
لرصد حاله الناس قلق الناس رعب الناس على
الارض في تركيا سوريا لبنان ودول اخرى
لانه هذه يعني قلقت كثيرا وتضررت كثيرا في
الواقع وتالمت كثيرا منذ سادس من فبراير
استاذ احمد ابو لؤي الصحفي من ادلب معي
نعم نعم
للخطط
طيب هذه صور الان للحظات الاولى للزلزال
منها طاير نتابعها قبل ان نعود اليك استاذ
احمد اذا نتابع هذه الصور الاولى
للحظه الزلزال فيها طائفه
سواء مرعبه بدون شك عاشتها هاتاي التركيه
مع كل المناطق والدول التي شاملها هذا
الزلزال مع الهزات الارتداديه التي شعر
بها الناس في مناطق ودول عديده شرق
المتوسط اذا هذه هي الصور للحظات الاولى
لوقوع الزلزال فيها تاي
بتركيا حيث تهتز الارض بكل ما عليها بوضوح
اذا ونحن نتابع هذه الصور الاولى التي
تصلنا للحظات الاولى لوقوع الزلزال فيها
طايبي تركيا نتابع رست المشهد طيب بعد
اسمحلي احمد ارجع
معنا الان استاذ غسان سويدان اذا جاهزا
استاذ غسان سويدان رئيس مركز رصد الزلازل
الاردني من عمان اهلا بك انا اريد يعني ان
اسالك عن
يعني تحليلك وفق المعطيات الوارده حتى
الان لما حصل
تمام سيدي الله يعطيك العافيه ونسال الله
العفو والعافيه والسلامه للجميع ان شاء
الله لاخواننا في تركيا وفي سوريا ان شاء
الله يا ربي يا سيدي ما حصل يعني قد يبدو
متوقع
علميا قد نكون ان نقول ان الطاقه الكامنه
في باطل الارض التي انفجرت يوم
6/2000 قد
ظهر منها شيء على السطح وقد قامت ببعض
الازاحه في المناطق التركيه وقد نقول قد
هذا كله علميا والله اعلم انه انتقلت الى
مكان اخر الطاقه هذه انتقلت الى مكان وهو
مكان ضعف ومن هناك انبثقت هذا ما نستطيع
قوله
انتقلت هذه الطاقه الى مكان اخر
يعني احنا بنقول انه الزلزال اللي صار
بالساس من فبراير حرر طاقه كامله في الارض
كانت عباره عن تجمع واجهادات للصخور كبيره
على مدى سنوات سابقه هذه الطاقه تحررت
واخرجت الزلازل التي تكلمنا عنها في شهر
اثنين اللي من 16 يوم
يقال ان هذه قد تنتقل بالفوالق او الفواصل
او الصدوع باتجاه الغرب يعني هذا الزلزال
اللي حصل اليوم قد يبعد عن الزلازل اللي
حصلت بحدود ال300 كيلو متر
تم تحريض المنطقه وتفريغ الطاقه من هذه
الجهه الموضوع مستمر هيك بالايام المقبله
يعني في تخوف من انه يضل هذه الطاقه تحييد
لمناطق اخرى شيئا فشيئا
طبعا كل زلزال يتميز عن الاخر وكل زلزال
له طبيعته المختلفه عن الاخر ما حصل في
قبل اسبوعين كان عباره عن تضاغط وتصادم
بين صفيحتين الان احنا بنتكلم عن انزلاق
لطبقات صخريه كبيره اخرى او زلزال من نوع
مختلف على صدع نفس الصدع هذا باتجاه الشرق
عفوا باتجاه الغرب
نتوقع نتوقع وبكثره وجود بعض الزلازل
المرتده وهاي يعني مشاهد لغايه الان 13 او
14 زلزال مرتاد قوتهم اربعه
واربعه وشوي فيعني لا نستغرب 14 زلزال
الان يعني من سته فبراير للان نعد 14
زلزالا مع الهزازات
الليله نعم لا لا انا اتكلم عن زلزال
الليله فقط
الثامنه او خمس دقائق نعم حدث 14 زلزال
ارتدادي لغايه الان يعني
خلط عند الجميع بهذا الموضوع بينما هو
زلزال جديد وما هو لا يزال هزات ارتداديه
نعم سيدي
ما حصل انا اتوقع او انا اعتقد انه هو
زلزال جديد قوه سته واربعه بالعشره مكان
يبعد عن او عن المناطق الاولى التي حصلت
في 6 فبراير يبعد 300 كيلو متر الى الغرب
والان نشاهد زلازل الارتداديه
صور من جبله السوريه اذا الان تصلنا تبقى
معنا استاذ غسان لو تكرمت اذا صور تصلنا
لحاله
مواطني وسكان جبله السوريه بعد هذا
الزلزال الذي حصل الليله حلب والرعب
يعيشها الاهالي في مدينه جبله السوريه بعد
الزلزال كما حصل في العديد من المدن
الاخرى في تركيا وسوريا ولبنان
يعني الشكل الاكبر حتى الان الناس تخشى من
العوده الى بيوتها الى شققها الى منازلها
بسبب ما حصل تخشى من الهزات الارتداديه
التي من الطبيعي ان يعني بدون ان ما نخوف
الناس ولكننا طبيعي انه قد تحصل استاذ
غسان الليله
وفي الايام المقبله
نعم صحيح
ليس هناك شيء مستبعد نتكلم عن زلزال قوه
سته وثلاثه بالعشره سته واربعه بالعشره
هذا يعتبر من الزلازل القويه الزلازل
الممكن ان تدمر بعض المناطق القريبه
وخاصه نوعيه بناء معينه
لا نستبعد نهائيا استمرار الهزات
الارتداديه وان شاء الله انه يعني يكون
الامور افضل مما نتوقع نحن
خطر ارتفاع منسوب البحر اجا تحذيرات بشانه
بعدين الغيها من السلطات والاعلام التركي
يعني ما حقيقه الموضوع في هذه الحاله
علميا
نعم سمعت وقرات انا على الاخبار ولكني لست
على اطلاع يعني ما حصل وان شاء الله انه
ما يكون في اي نوع من الامواج تسونانيه او
ارتفاع للبحر رغم انه هو زلزال يعني موقع
الزلزال قريب جدا الى البحر يعني ليس
بالبعيد يعني اتوقع انه هو مركزه قريب
خمسين كيلو من البحر باتجاه الشرق طيب
الان يعني ولكن هذا لا يعني انه تفضل بس
اسالك
كمتخصص يعني هل يعني ما هي الاجراءات
الواجب اتباعها الان من الناس لانه في
حاله هلع ورعب في في كثير من الدول
المعنيه
نعم صحيح
ما نشاهد الان الوقت متاخر اصبح ليلا
قد الناس يخافوا العوده الى منازلهم وهذا
حقهم الطبيعي قد يكون هناك خلخله في بعض
المباني يعني انا ما بعرف شو راح يتصرف
السلطات او الناس يعني ممكن تلجا الى بيوت
اكثر امنا او بيوت مثلا تتكون من طابق
ارضي واحد او يعني يهجروا العمارات
العاليه
اتوقع هذا ما سيحصل مع الناس او قد يلجا
الى بعض المدارس او الملاجئ في كثير يعني
نظريات مؤامره مثل ما بتعرف استاذ غسان
بتحليلات الناس هل كل ما يحصل الان طبيعي
مئه بالمئه قد يحصل في التاريخ وفي اي
مكان معرض للزلازل
من غيرها اي دول اي مناطق من هذه الدول
في تركيا سوريا لبنان وماذا ايضا استاذ
غسان
هو اكثر المناطق تاثرا هي المناطق الجنوب
التركي الشرق الشرقي عفوا الغربي والشمال
الغربي من سوريا هذه الاكثر مناطق تعرضا
وقد لا نستبعد وجود بعض التاثيرات على
قبرص لانه بعيد عن المنطقه جزيره قبرص
بالبعيد عن المنصحه في حال حدوث امواج
امواج مائيه قد تصل الى تركيا الى قبرص
بكل سهوله
تبقى معنا اتوقع انه لبنان بعيده بعض
الشيء تفضل
بعيده تفضل تابع باي معنى لانه عم يشعروا
بالهزات بالارتداديه
هلا اتوقع انه لبنان يعني الشمال اللبناني
الى حدود الى بؤره الزلزال اتوقع فوق
ال250 كيلو متر يبعد
تبقى معنا معلش نرجع لزيدان نشوف شو الوضع
الان ما مشاهداتك
نعم نحن الان كنا نحاول التوجه الى دفنه
المنطقه التي
وقع فيها الزلزال لكن حقيقه الطرق السيئه
لاحظنا في بعض الطرق التي
كنا فيها او التي مررنا بها
ظهر هذا اليوم في انطاكيا هناك ضرر اضافي
في هذه الطرق طبعا هناك وسائل تركيا تقول
ان مبنى ولايه
مبنى ولايه الان بات خارج الخدمه لكن لا
نستطيع تاكيد على المعلومه هل تم اخلاقه
بسبب احترازات الامنيه او الاجراءات
الامنيه او
بالفعل هو تضرر لا يستطيع حتى الان الوصول
الى هناك لكن
اثناء التوجه الى منطقه دفنه العديد من
السكان
وقد ق
ريبه طبعا رئيس كان يطلب تامين خيام
للاشخاص الذين خرجوا الى الشوارع بعد
استمرار الهزات الاعتداديه وتجاوز عدد
الهزازات الابتدائيه 20 هزت طائر حتى هذه
اللحظه نعود الى مشاهداتك بعد قليل نذهب
الى اضنه عبد القادر خربوش مراسل العربيه
موفد العربيه عبد القادر ماذا لديك
نعم نعم طاهر انا في اضنه وصلت للتو واول
ما الفتني هنا في هذه المدينه هو وجود
العائلات خارج مساكنها رغم ان هذه الولايه
تبعد عن مقر الهزه الجديده او الزلزال
الجديد الذي ضرب هاتاي بحوالي 200 كيلومتر
شعر بها سكان هذه المدينه باضنه وخرجوا
مثل ما تشاهد في هذه الصور الان مباشره
العائلات في العراء هناك خوف وذعر ورغم
البرد لا يريدون الدخول الى البنايات
يتوقعون رغم البرد نعم هناك مشاهد اخرى
سننقلها من هذا الجانب هناك عائلات داخل
السيارات يبدو انهم سيقضون ليلتهم هذه
داخل السيارات هناك خوف من ان يحدث امر
جلل ربما زلزال اخر يضرب المنطقه نشاهد
عائله باكملها الان داخل هذه السياره
حاول معهم ان نعرف مرحبا الف سلامه عليكم
ليش انتم
يقول بانه هناك مترجم طبعا يساعدني في
الترجمه ان لا يستطيعون المكود داخل البيت
عندما شاهدوا
احسوا بزلزال الاخير وهو متخوفون من
الدخول الى البيت سنشاهد ايضا من هذا
الجانب هناك عده عائلات طاهر موجود هنا
بالخارج من كبار السن اطفال
شيوخ شباب من مختلف الاعمار هناك ايضا
مساحه بوسط اضنه يعني يتم الان الاحتشاد
بالخارج خوفا من من وقوع زلزال اخر هناك
بهذا الجانب هناك عدد كبير من العائلات
عند جانب الطريق وهم الان اصبحوا خبراء
حتى في طريقه الاحتماء ربما مما قد يح
جراء زلزال نشاهد هناك بنايات بعيده نوعا
ما عن هذا المكان لكنهم يحتمون في المناطق
شبه الخاليه
بالقرب من حديقه او مكان فارغ نشاهده هنا
فهم يعني يحتمون بهذه المناطق سنحاول
التقرب منهم لمعرفه ممكن عن مخاوفهم مع
الاخبار التي تلت نعم نعم عن هذه الهزات
المتتاليه التي تلت ايضا هذا الزلزال
الجديد
طاهر سنحاول معهم طبعا هناك مرحبا هناك من
لا يريد الحديث لكن نشاهد الان حتى هناك
من اخذ معه بطانيته وهذا دليل على ان على
انه ربما سيقضي ليلته هنا في العراء خوفا
من وقوع اي شيء ربما سيء مرحبا
لماذا انتم في الخارج وليس في البيوت
احكي لي ليش ليش طلعتوا على برا طلعنا
حسيتوا بها يعني كانت قويه
كم دامت الطويله قصيره زي الهزه الاولى او
الزلزال اللي ضرب قبل اسبوعين حبيت
طويله
كانت فيها زاد كثيره يعني بعد الزلزال
الكبير الذي ضرب المنطقه كنت تشعر بها
بنفس القوه ام هذه اكبر بكثير هاي اكبر من
هيك اكبر من هيك وانتو اليوم كيف راح
تبقوا في العراق اما راح تدخلوا البيت
في جامع بالقرب من هون والجمع ما تخافوا
انه يسقط عليكم لا قدر الله لو صار زلزال
الله فيه
الله معنا
خلي يصير معنا انت من سوريا الف سلامه
عليك السلام عليكم ان شاء الله
حتى استسلام ربما قد يحصل هذا الشخص يقول
بانه سيذهب الى الجامع بالمدينه ويقضي
ليلته اليوم هناك ولا يابه بما قد يحصل
ربما ليلا ان اهتزت الارض مجددا وهدم لا
نتمناه طبعا لكن هناك تطمينات رسميه ترد
على لسان
الناطقين باسم الرئاسه وايضا وزير
الداخليه بان كانت هناك تحذيرات ايضا من
ربما وقوع او ارتفاع منسوب للمياه للبحر
جراء الزلزال الاخير وتم الغاء هذا النداء
وهذا التحذير ايضا كان وزير الداخليه يقول
بانه لا خوف اكبر من تبعات ربما هذه الهزه
خصوصا وان الهزات
التي تلت الزلزال الاخير كانت اقل درجه
بالمقارنه الى قوه الزلزال الذي تجاوز
السته سته درجات على سلم ريختر وبدات تخف
نوعا ما الهزات الارتداديه التي تلت هذا
الزلزال طاهر تبقى معنا ونعود اليك في
سياق هذه التغطيه شكرا جزيلا على كل هذه
المعلومات من اضنه موفد العربيه عبد
القادر خربوش واعود الى هاتايما زيدان
زينكلو مع المعلومات التي
تريدنا اذا عن اخلاء مركز اداره الكوارث
هناك
وزيره الصحه ودفاع تركيا ان يخليان مركز
اداره الكوارث في هاتاي ووزير الداخليه
التركيه توجه الى هناك للوقوف على تداعيات
الزلزال الاخير اذا صور الانهيارات جزئيه
في بعض الابنيه بهاتاي التركيه نتابعها
على الهواء
كما تصلنا اذا من وسائل اعلام تركيا تضرر
وتصدع وتشقق يعني سقوط لبعض اجزاء
الجدران والمباني في هاتاي التركيه الاكثر
تضررا كمركز لهذا الزلزال الذي حصل الليله
نعرف اكثر من زيدان
بالفعل طاهر قبل قليل او قبل الثواني فقط
جاءت الانباء بانه وزير الداخليه
سليمان توجه الى اثار بطاقه بعد وقوع
الزلزال وايضا وزير الصحه والدفاع اخليان
مركز اداره الكوارث وطوارئ في اتاي وانتقل
الى اداره العمليات في الغرف المتنقده
المخصصه من قبل هيئه الطوارئ طبعا
ذكرت قبل قليل ان مبنى ولايه خرج عن
الخدمه جرائد زلزال لكن لم نتاكد حتى الان
من
من هذه المعلومه مئه في المئه هل خرج عن
الخدمه بسبب ضرر في جسم المبنى ام
بسبب
اخلاء المبنى كاجراء احترازي هذه مثلا
تاكد منها قبل قليل واعيد الاخبار التي
ذكرتها عليكم طاهر قبل
قليل ايضا رئيس بلديه سمندات كان يطلب
المزيد من القيام لان الكثير من السكان
سوف او خرجوا الى العراء يعني هذه الحالات
تقريبا هو سيناريو مكرر لما عشناه في
الزلزال الماضي او في الزلزال الكبير في
السادس من شباط فبراير
المئات من سكان الولايات الجنوبيه تفضلوا
البقاء او المبيت داخل سياراتهم الخاصه
على العوده الى المنازل حتى لو لم تتضرر
تلك المنازل الكثير منهم كان يفضل البقاء
وبقي ليله وليلتان في السياره
الحاله يبدو انها ستتكرر هذه الليله مع
حاله الهلع والخوف الشديدين طاهر لا يمكن
وصف
المشاعر يعني حقيقه
سكان تحديدا لم يستفيقوا من صدمه الزلزال
الاول الذي ضرب المدينه وكانت من اكثر
الولايات تضررا واكثر الولايات التي شهدت
اشخاص فارقوا الحياه بسبب الزلزال واكثر
نتحدث تحديدا عن مدينه انطاكيا مركز
الولايه اكثر المدن التضررا كانت انطاكيا
في هاتاي واكثر القتله كانوا في انطاكيا
في هاد طبعا
الطواقم الموجوده هناك حاله انه احاول
الوصول
نقاط عقاد مع الاسف حتى الان نحن رح نقوم
في
ازدحام السير وايضا طبعا بسبب تفريغ
الطرقات لسيارات الاسعاف للتوجه الى
المناطق التي اتت اليها او التي اتت منها
اخبار وجود اشخاص عالقين تحت الانقاذ كما
ذكرت يعني او في تصريح
لنائب الرئيس التركي كان تحدث عن وجود
ثمانيه جرحه بسبب
الزلزال في هاتاي
رائد صالح رئيس مجموعه القوات البيضاء
يقول الان انه المشافي والمراكز الطبيه
حتى الان سجلت بحسب ما بالغه من معلومات
اكثر من 125 اصابه
125 اصابه في شمال غرب سوريا بعد الزلزال
الذي ضرب المنطقه اغلب هذه الاصابات كانت
ناجمه عن الخوف والهلع او القفز من الا او
حالات اغماء اذا يؤكد ايضا ان فرق القوات
البيضاء في استنفار كامل للاستجابه لاي
طارق
ونتابع في تغطيتنا هذه
لحاله الهلع والرعب في تركيا في سوريا في
لبنان بعد هذا الزلزال الاخير الكثير من
الهزات الارتداديه التي حصلت والهزات
الارتداديه المتوقعه ايضا في الساعات
المقبله وهذا الذي يبقي الناس في الشوارع
يعني ليناموا فيها ان كان في العراء او في
سياراتهم او في الخيام
لكي يعني يتقوا شر اي زلزال او هزه
ارتداديه عنيفه اخرى قد تضرب مناطقهم اذن
هذه اخر الاخبار التي تردنا من المناطق
المتضرره
وبالتالي خاصه في الجانب التركي مع توجه
وزير الداخليه الى هاتاي للوقوف على
تداعيات الزلزال الاخير ما ابرز ما كانت
وعدت به زيدان السلطات التركيه
لتقدمه
وليزيد زلزال الحالي طينه بيلا في هذا
الاطار بدون شك
لم اسمع
كنت اسالك كنت اسالك عن نشاهد صور جديده
اعذرني نشاهد صورا جديده او يعني
لحظات قبل قليل ولكن نعرضها الان اذا من
اين اذا هذه صورها ايضا في هاتاي مركز
الزلزال حيث انت ونتابع ما يمكن رصده فيها
من عرضنا هذه الصوره من قبل اذن
وهذه اضنه الان اذا لحظه حدوث الزلزال
لحظه وقوع الزلزال في اوباما التركيه هذه
الصور نراها جديده اذا على عكس السابقه
المكرره نتابع
اذا كل الناس واضح انها هرعت الى الخارج
لحظه وقوع زلزال في اضنه بتركيا يعني في
احد الامكنه هناك لا اعرف اذا كان يعني
مطعما او ما شابه على كل حال اعود اليك
كنت اسالك عن طبيعه الوعود يعني ما فتات
سلطات تركيه تعد المواطنين بتقديم الاموال
والخدمات والتعويضات الى ما هناك بفعل
الزلزال الاول حتى الان يعني اصبحت امام
واقع اكثر مراره ربما مع مطالبات بتوفير
خيام للمشردين للمشردين من بيوتهم في بعض
المناطق ما لما كانت السلطات التركيه
تداب على فعله
كي ترضي الناس وتخفف من روعهم ومشاكلهم
نعم لا شك ان التعويضات الماليه بدات
اليوم بالسلطات التركيه بصرف التعويضات
الماليه او على وجه التحديد نهايه الاسبوع
الماضي اليوم عنده وصولنا الى انطاكيا
وامام البنك الزراعي او زراعات بنك كما
يسمى هنا شاهدنا الطوابير طويله من السكان
بانتظار دورهم لاستلام المعونه الماليه
وكانت قد اعلنت الحكومه التركيه توفير او
منح كل اسره في المناطق مصدره مبلغ 10,000
ليره تركيه اليوم كانت هناك صوابير
وازدحام امام البنوك الحكوميه التي تقدم
هذه المبالغ الماليه للمتضررين من الزلزال
كان هناك محاولات جاده نعم طاهر لتوفير
المزيد من القيام الرئيس التركي تحدث عن
ارسال اكثر من 200 الف خيمه وكانت المساعي
الحكوميه تتجه لتوفير حوالي 200 الف فك
مؤقت وهم عباره عن مساكن مسبقاع اضافه الى
لنقل السكان من الخيام الى هذه الاماكن
المؤقته طبعا هناك اعداد كبيره من سكان
الولايات الجنوبيه ومن هاتاي تحديدا
انتقلوا الى ولايات اكثر امنا
خصوصا ممن فقدوا منازلهم او ان منازلهم
تضررت بشكل كبير
جراء الزلزال لذلك
في جنديرس اذا هذه صور لتهدد بعض المباني
وكنا سمعنا عن هذه الانباء اذا مع يعني
التذكير بان عددها ثلاثه مباني في جدارس
بسوريا جراء الهزه الارضيه الاخيره هذه
المنطقه التي تضررت كثيرا في الواقع بفعل
الزلزال الاول الكبير في السادس من فبراير
معنا الصحفيه احمد ابو لؤي الان طيب لم
يعد معنا اذن قد نعود اليه
استاذ غسان سويدان لا تزال معنا
استاذ غسان سويدان مركز رصد الزلازل
الاردني كنا نتحدث قبل قليل عن ابرز
المناطق
المعرضه
الزلازل والهزات الارتداديه الان نقرا
الكثير من الاخبار عن التفرقه بينما يكون
مركز البحر او لا يكون مركز البحر
وبالتالي يعتمد عليه
مدى او حجم المخاطر التي يمكن ان تنجم عن
الزلازل بناء على تسونامي على الاقل كيف
يمكن ان نفرق في ذلك
سيدي يعني هذا هو مركزه
اليابسه وقد لا يكون بعيد عن البحر يعني
ممكن الدفع الطاقه اللي تحررت بتذهب الى
الغرب اللي هي باتجاه البحر ولا نستبعد
حدوث بعض الامواج تسونانيه في المنطقه
يعني هو ليس ببلعيد عن البحر هو ليس في
البحر ولكن
يعني كم ساعه او كم يوم او
والله يعني ما في شيء يعني مستبعد ولكن قد
يعني نعطيه عشر ساعات 15 ساعه بهذه الحدود
يعني لانه لا زالت هناك هل ذات ارتداديه
والهزات الارتداديه اللي حصلت هي ليست
بالضعيفه يعني تتكلم قوه اربعه قوه ثلاثه
ونصف فيعني هم
ليست بالزلازل الصغيره
على طبيعته
نعم صحيح هلا كلما كان الزلزال ضحل اي انه
قريب الى السطح فان الدمار يكون اكبر
وكلما كان
عميق فاننتقل شدته الزلزال اللي حصل اليوم
يعني كان مبدئيا انه هو على عمر خمسه كيلو
متر فهو من الزلازل يعني القويه وضحلها اي
ان تاثير سوف يكون كبير على اليابسه او
على المباني وعلى الناس تمام
رئيس مركز راس الزلازل الاردني من عمان
نعود الى احمد ابو لؤي الصحفي الان اهلا
بك ماذا يقول الناس وكيف هو حالهم الان
الناس الان مئات العائلات في
الطرقات ما زالوا طبعا يعني
ضربه يعني قويه في الثقافيه اربعه يعني
توتر على الطقس تحت الدرجات للحراره تحت
الصفر يعود التهجير من جديد يعني هنالك
العديد من الناس الذين
هربوا من الزلزال الاول يعني بعد الياس
وبقائهم في الطرقات لايام يعني عادوا
لمنازلهم لابنيتهم التي لا تعتبر يعني لكن
من جديد يعودون للتهجير هنالك نساء شيوخ
اطفال ما زالوا في الطرقات
بانتظار مناجاهتهم يعني توتر اصبح ملحوظ
بشكل كبير حاله من الهلع والخوف هنالك عده
اصابات طبعا نتيجه الزلزال لكن نتيجه
الهلع الخوف الاسراع عنهم من يعني رمى
نفسه من طوابق اولى من اجل ان لا بالتالي
ما هي الحجيات الاساسيه الان ما هي الحاجه
الماسه لماذا عند الناس
الان يعني بشكل اسعافي هنالك حاجه ماسه
للخيام رقم واحد اثنين بالفرشات للبطانيات
يعني
طبعا هذا الحاجه يعني بهذه اللحظات طبعا
هنالك دخل العديد من المساعدات لكن لا
تكفي لتغطيه ثمانيه او عشره بالمئه من
حالات الناس هنالك العائله
الضربه الاولى وحتى اليوم اليوم يعود
العديد والالاف من يهاجرون يخرجون من
مناديلهم يعني التي تصدعت الخوف في ارقهم
اصبح كما ذكرت ملحوظ يعني الكارثه تتفاقم
بكل اختصار تبقى معنا استاذ احمد ابو لؤي
في هذه التغطيه ولكن يعني نختمها في هذه
الساعه ويتابع فيها صهيب شرايب بعد قليل